Oh
Hey
Ah, good enough for those supplies
Can you hear me okay? How's the volume?
I hope everything's okay
I'm gonna pamper you
Turn up the volume then
Today, I'm gonna pamper you
Because you did such a good job
It's been a long day
And I felt like it's a nice day
So, don't you want to kiss me again?
Shhh, I'm scared
Okay
How about I whisper a little loud?
Is that better?
Okay
How about I whisper a little louder?
Is that better?
Okay
It's much better, okay
I'm so sorry
Today, I'm going to pamper my supplies
I went out and got so many things for my supplies
I hope you like them
Can you hear this?
These are the papples that you guys were talking about
These are the papples I cried
The crack pipes, they're not really crack pipes
They're ice rollers
It's not blood
Oh my goodness
Can't give you a second if it's still too quiet
I don't know how I can whisper even louder
Okay, hold on
I got this, okay, audio keeps cutting out
Okay, give me a second
I'm so sorry, I'm so new to this
Okay
Is this better?
I turned it off
Now, now, everything, can you hear everything?
Okay, so bye
I'm going to use the ice rollers on you and massage your face
I hope it feels good
Can you feel it on your eyes?
These ice rollers are great for public eyes
Your eyes, yes, sometimes it's really this small
And so, if you put these in the fridge, it has to pop in
And if you want more of it, good
It just relaxes with the supply
It covers
I'm just going to treat you
Okay
I'm going
These ones might make a little bit of a different sound
Because the bubbles, the head is actually shaped like moles
So the moons might make a little bit of a different sound
That would be a mistake
Thank you for the rate, middle
Middle
I'm glad you like it so far
Edithal, welcome, welcome to the stream
Doing ASMR is my first time ever
Trying ASMR
Okay
Left eye massage
Right eye one
Doing this on
I don't know which to use
Anyway, I'm going to try the left eye massage
Left eye massage
Head on
I have a one day ASMR special spot
And put this on my lap
Bring it back up
I want something simple
It's brand new, let's open it
Almost got it on your ear there
It's a box cutter, let's open this package now
Let's open this package
Let's open it
Shhh, and toss this in trash now
I bought you a gel
A gel mask for you to wear
The back is nice and plush
A lot of gel balls are rolling around
I'm going to angle this because you're laying on my lap so far
I'm not going to lie, this feels really good to squish as well
Alright, let's put this around except my
Oh dear, I need some scissors
Let's cut the tag off
There we go
Sorry that made a big sound
Alright
No eye patch today
Today the eye patch stays on so I can look at your eyes and look into my eyes
Okay, I'm putting it on now so far
Let me adjust it for you
Does it feel comfortable Senpai?
Do you feel like it's relaxing your eyes?
I'll massage on top of it
Okay
You must be so tired
Can I scratch your face?
It's like Senpai
Good
Good, I'm so glad you're so glad
I love you Senpai
There we go
One kiss, we don't want to get in trouble
Let's have a ear massage
I had a ear massage once, it was really nice
I'm just gonna copy them, I hope
I hope that Senpai feels good too
A little ear massages
I'm gonna go a little bit deeper
Okay, I'm gonna go a little deeper
I'm trying to be as gentle as I can
Okay
Nice and relaxed
I love you Senpai
Let's massage the top of your ear and your ear
Okay
Wow, hey, yeah, it did so well this week Senpai
It did so well this week
I'm so proud
We're doing so well, we're doing so well
And
Oh, Senpai
Okay, you got hair on your face
Okay, don't worry, I got it
Doesn't hurt each other
Piyoto intimate
If you also love it, it doesn't hurt to shine
Okay
You want me to call a good girl?
Good girl
You've been so very good
The week, we're halfway through the week
So you can relax
You can relax and have a lot of fun on the weekend
You've been so good
Good girl
Hold on Senpai, let me take this mask off
Good boy
You did so good this week
You're halfway through the week
And you have such a fun weekend
I'm sorry I was quiet before
It's just that
I don't know how close I can get to you Senpai
I'm a little shy
So getting too close
Makes me a little nervous
This is close enough
Does it feel good?
Scream into your ear, no thank you
Some of my Senpais
Might not like that
Senpai
Are you feeling relaxed now?
Okay
I'm so glad that
Let's bring these back
These
They were sitting in my lap
So they're a little warm
Just like you
These waterfalls are a little bit different
They're shaped like moons
So they kind of remind me of Sailor Moon Wands
Presum, power
Makeup
If you scratch my forehead
Kill this one
Okay
Is that better?
No, it's not a magical girl, R.P.
I just think they look like Sailor Moon Wands
I know what you're really like
In the name of the moon
I'll punish you
Okay
I'm sorry, I'm trying to
To suppress my laugh
Oh no, I don't want to be loud, I know some of you, I know some of you are trying to
huh?
These actually really sound nice, these sound so nice, right?
Signers, he found it in stores, I thought of him for a few seconds
huh?
Do you want the scissors back?
What kind of scissors?
This, it's a gel mask, it's a gel mask with little gel balls in it, it's got a plush back
ok
oops, almost cut your ear off
hahaha
what about right in front of me?
I'm sorry, I'm sorry, I got a little excited
I got a little excited, I'm sorry
I'm sorry
here
that's it
here, let's put it back
that's not bad
wow, I can wipe it off
there you go
I'm going to tap on your highlight
sorry, I don't have any bandages on me right now
sorry
you always look perfect so far
always
kiss me
ok
your ears are just fine, your ears are just fine
your face is still beautiful
you are doing great
sorry, I got a little rough
I guess some instincts took over
it's not just anything you did, it's me
I don't think it's going to work, I don't want you to do that
ok
here, take some ear massages
I don't think it will work
I love you so much
I love you so much so much
you did so well
I'm sorry
I hate you
not this time
I love you
you're so good
good girl
you've been such a good girl
you've been such a good boy
bye
toki toki
that's how
my heart beats for you
good
meow meow
now
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait
wait
ok, now try just reuse it by
toasted coconuts
Cabbage, cabbages, cabbages, like this is, like this is, like this is.
6, 6, card.
Stop it, stop it, bye.
Where is my super scent?
I said why is my super scent?
Papi, Papi.
Do you want to hear the sound? Do you want to hear the sound? Do you want to hear the sound?
Ten amour, ten amour.
Give yourself a good example, you're so pretty.
Give yourself a good example.
Do you want to hear the sound? Do you want to hear the sound? Do you want to hear the sound? Do you want to hear the sound?
Can I make that blue song?
Do you want to hear the sound?
Do you like it past, like this?
Okay, I can keep doing this, right?
As long as you're feeling relaxed and fine, that's all that matters. Water, give me a moment, I'll be extra gentle with you.
Water, give me a moment.
Water, give me a moment, I'll be extra gentle with you.
I'm trying to be as tame as possible so that my supplies go to sleep and wake up, maybe able to see my sleep.
I'm tapping on you.
I hope that's correct or not.
I'm a little stuffed up so it will sound disgusting if I...it will sound disgusting.
My favorite deep end, um, when that's on sale.
Can I burp the outfit? No, I can't burp a little on command. I can't burp on command.
The image turned out to be my little poncho.
My good little pets.
YouTube doesn't punish me. I wonder if YouTube, I wonder if YouTube is different in each region, depending on their DOS.
Because I know a lot of JPAs are a little bit more on the sexy side, but they don't get attacked.
I can't stream before using a VPN because it's faster. It's not fast. It will let you go crazy.
OBS doesn't recognize different regions and will not let you stream if you use a VPN. It's very hard to deal with.
So, I have to abide by the rules.
Okay. You can be good, right, Senpai, and follow the rules with me.
Right, you can follow the rules, right? My heartbeat.
I'm not going to lie, Senpai. You're kind of heavy, so I can't put you on my chest.
Sorry, Senpai.
Well, please, you. The microphone is kind of heavy, didn't it?
The 3DL, the stand I put it on, a little bit.
Better.
Okay.
When I get a new stand to Senpai, I'll put you on my chest and then give you my heartbeat. Okay?
Are smaller than you can hear my heartbeat. Right now, it's a little heavy.
If I lift this up, I can lift it up a little bit, but it's quite heavy.
I can probably use this to break your head in, Senpai. It can probably smash a few skulls in.
I'll try my best, Senpai, but I can't make any problems.
Okay, it takes a little while for you to smell.
I don't have it on me, so I might take a while.
I don't want to spook you with my keyboard, and...
Yeah, I don't want to spook you with my keyboard, and my keyboard and mouse, they're kind of loud.
Oh, yeah.
Senpai, here's that one.
Okay.
Although I might become numb.
Bad boy, bad girl.
I'll tell you why I won't fall asleep on stream.
It's a funny story. Actually, maybe not now, it's not the time for it. It's a little too silly.
It's a little too silly, and I think, uh, it will definitely ruin the mood.
I almost said that thing, I'm sorry.
No, no, I don't want to yab too much.
I just want to explain the situation with ASMR, and why some of the laws are being taken down.
Otherwise, you might have a bite in trouble here.
Darling, darling, you're my good girl, you're mine.
You're my good boy, you're mine.
I can lie by Senpai's hips on her legs.
Senpai, stay here with me Senpai. You like staying here with me, right?
I'm so happy that you're here.
I've waited so long for something so nice to be with.
If you stay here, I'll try to make you as happy as I can. Okay?
Of course.
So, I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my, I'm trying my best.
Even if this is my first time ASMR, and all my Senpais are good,
I've never used triggers before.
Frankly, I didn't know what a trigger was, but now I'm letting so much free use of fun.
I'm not sure if this is the correct way of doing it.
Trigger, trigger.
Yes, she explained what a countdown was.
You won't get it though, Senpai.
Naughty.
Naughty, naughty Senpai.
Get it?
Give me the strength.
Not this time.
I'm not going to fall for this.
You think I'm stupid Senpai?
I can't say that I won't fall for this. Sometimes I might be absent-minded.
Then you got me Senpai.
You tricked me.
But not today.
Especially with not the nice big brother YouTube watching.
You can set a timer by yourself Senpai.
Couple.
Now what?
I cupped one ear.
I cupped one ear now what?
Like this.
Now what?
No, seriously.
No, I just go out on this.
Oh really?
Is it like this?
No.
Okay.
Wow.
I'm a little scared.
But I got it.
Like this.
I'm going to put more pressure on you.
Let's move this out of the way.
Okay.
I'm going to put pressure on you.
Maybe you can turn to the other side.
Okay.
Sorry.
I'm sorry.
It was my elbow.
I'm going to put pressure on you.
Okay.
Deep breaths.
I think that's too silly.
I'm sorry.
I got too silly.
I didn't know what you meant.
I'm sorry.
Okay.
Now we are going to get back into this.